الات بحيره امش جوجل الواقعه امام جبل
طويق في مدينه الرياض بمياه الامطار التي
تشهدها مدن ومحافظات العاصمه هذا الاسبوع
كما تشهد ايضا مناطق شرق وغرب وشمال
السعوديه امطار متفرقه بين متوسطه وزيره
[موسيقى]
بحيره المشقوق في شمال الرياض ينضم لنا
مراسل العربيه
مرحبا بك
كيف المشهد عندك
محمد عبده
وتطعيس الوجه
يكفي انا طال عمرك وصوتك ههه
اخر مره شهاده
اتساع في كميه مياه الامطار اللي تشدها
المناطق مختلفه من السعوديه كانت قبل 10
اعوام لم تمتلئ بحيره ام شقوق الواقعه
امام جبل طويق والعله الجبال التي نشاهدها
في الامام هناك هي سلسله جبال الطويك طبعا
هذه البحيره هي تقع في شمال غرب العاصمه
الرياض طبعا كان اخر مدى لها في الحدود
التي وضعتها الجهات المعنيه من خلال وضع
الخرسانات على هذه المحميه وهي كونها
محميه من اجل الحفاظ على غطاء النباتي
وكذلك الطيور المهاجره ولكن الان نشاهد
كميه مياه الامطار قد خطت هذه المحميه
لتصل الى مسافات قريبه منا جدا الان نتحدث
عن مساحه تتجاوز او الجاز تتجاوز طول
البحيره الان اكثر من كيلوون كيلو ونصف
الكيلو متر وهي يعني مساحه شاسعه لم
تشهدها تحديدا بحيره ام شقوق وهذا بالجليل
ان كميه الامطار التي تجدها العاصمه
الرياض او كذلك منطقه الرياض اا كانت قد
كانت كمياتها كبيره في الاسبوع الحالي
يعني لان كنا نتحدث مع المتنزهين وكذلك
همم دائما من المتنازين الذي كانوا يقومون
بزياره ام شقوق وايضا الاستمتاع في
مناظرها من خلال الغطاء النباتي الموجود
والتي قامت بها الجهات المعنيه
بزياده زراعه اشجار الطلح والاثل وكذلك
الازهار المختلفه البريه التي تلائم
ومتلائ مع الطبيعه البريه هنا في هذه
المنطقه طبعا ايضا نتحدث عن عن مشروع اخر
هناك مشاريع في حمايه البيئه وكذلك
الزراعيه ولكن في الجهه الاخرى من جبال
طويق والعلام يمكن الحاله الضبابيه الان
التي تشهدها المنطقه هنا قد تغطي ملامح
بسيطه من جبال طويق اذكر ايضا ان ان
الكميه الامطار ليس فقط كانت نشاهدها فقط
على البحيرات سواء فيهم مشكوك او كذلك
البحيرات الاخرى القريبه من منطقه الرياض
ولكن ايضا هذه الكثبان الرمليه او كانت
كثبان رمليه الان نشاهدها اقرب ما تكون
بحاله طينيه ونشاهد ايضا كلما حفرنا في
الاسفل نشاهد ما زالت كميه الرمال او كميه
الطين موجوده وهذا بدليل ان كميه الامطار
التي هطلت في هذه المنطقه كباقي مناطق
السعوديه التي تشهد امطار غزيره وكانت
ايضا التوقعات او التوقعات ما زالت مستمره
من قبل مركز الارصاد السعودي الذي يقوم
بعمل تنبيهات متقدمه اضافه الى الجهات
المعنيه التي تطير منها اداره كاميرا شويه
ونشوف كمان الناس
او نقف في منتصف البحيره وايضا لو يعطينا
المصور خالد ابو منصور
للجهه الاخرى من البحيره و نشاهد ايضا على
ارتفاعات عاليه همم هي همم السحب الرعديه
المنطره وتكون السحب الرعديه الممطره التي
ما زالت
مهيئه بهطول امطار ايضا غزيره على العاصمه
الرياض طبعا هناك منخفض جوي همم في
تحضيرات مركز
الارصاد الذي يقوم في تنبيهاته مؤخرا
والذي اشار الى ان فرص ان الفرصه مهيئه
بهطول امطار غزيره على العاصمه
لان نشوف عدد المتنازين هنا قليل لان
معظم البحيرات المائيه الموجوده او
القريبه من مدينه الرياض امتلات فالناس
يقومون بالذهاب الى البحيرات الاقرب لهم
وهي فرصه سمحت للمتنزهين سواء المقيمين في
العاصمه الرياض او كذلك سكانها او ايضا
السياحه الذين قدموا الحضور والمشاهده هذه
البحيرات المائيه وعقبال عندك يا خالد
شكرا جزيلا على هالجوله وهالطله الحلوه
المنطقه